the Palestinian armed group Islamic
Jihad says a ceasefire has been agreed
with Israel in Gaza after two days of
cross-border fighting these are live
pictures from Gaza where calm appears to
have been restored Egypt has been
mediating between the two sides the
escalation began after a senior leader
of Islamic Jihad was killed in an
Israeli airstrike well Rob Matheson
joins us on the phone now from West
Jerusalem Rob so what more details have
emerged about this ceasefire well we've
had no official confirmation down yet
for here in Israel that this is five
ceasefire is in place but it is being
widely reported in the media it is
expected to have gone in has it have
begun at about all 5:30 local time this
morning we have teams both in Gaza on
both the Israeli border with Gaza the
team in Gaza has been telling us that
since that time they have heard rockets
and explosions inside the Gaza the team
on the Israeli border with Gaza has been
saying that sirens have been sounding in
areas which are close to that border now
we should stress that whenever there has
been a sea star in the past this is the
pattern that does occur that it takes
time for the details and the
notifications of the ceasefire to be put
into place to calculate those and
therefore if there is a lessening in
attacks excuse me it usually takes a
little bit of time for that to take
place as far as the details of the
actual ceasefire itself a concern we're
hearing that Islamic Jihad has agreed to
stop firing rockets into Israel and it's
also going to make sure that protests
along the Gaza border are peaceful for
its part Israel says that it will no
longer do targeted killings has
committed to stop shooting protesters at
border fence interestingly there has not
yet been any mention of one key
requirement that the Islamic Jihad group
had put in place which was to ease the
blockade that is currently on Gaza this
Israel has put very strict controls over
who and what can be moved across the
border back and forth between Gaza
and Israel they say the user extractions
are necessary for security reasons to
stop the possibility of technology and
weapons and individuals being able to
get into Gaza to be able to build
armaments for the armed groups that are
inside the Gaza Strip but at the moment
the death toll in Gaza standing at about
thirty two there were air strikes prior
to the ceasefire being put in place and
rockets were being fired out of Gaza
particularly around midnight we heard
that there was a very significantly
large barrage of rockets that were aimed
into Israel predominantly towards Tel
Aviv but at the moment we're just
waiting to see when this ceasefire is
officially acknowledged and if it will
actually take time to die down all right
now Rob Mathison there in West Jerusalem
Rob thank you